[Music]
regina is up next in las vegas nevada
regina how can we help
i can hi dr dee thank you for taking my
call sure
um i'm going to get right at it i'm
currently on baby step two um i've been
working on the debt snowball for about
five years
and uh as of this friday i was throwing
a curveball i was
served with paperwork um from an
attorney that represented me in 2020
and basically he's basically calling my
note due i owe him 16 grand
so
in terms of my debt snowball i've i've
been up to three days trying to rework
it and trying to put priority in in mind
my concern is and my dilemma is
part of my debt snowball was the initial
payment i made him on the unpacked out
so how do i rework this debt snowball so
i can see a light at the end of the
tunnel
how much were you paying him each month
well i initially took out a 401k loan
because i had to i had no choices it was
based on my daughter and child support
so i had to have attorney i had to have
representation
so that was six thousand dollars i'm
still paying that back over a monthly
period on a payroll deduction basis
um and then i have a car loan and a
small loan over a thousand dollars
and um
so i just don't know which way to turn
as far as prioritizing because
i've been doing it three different ways
and i still can't see the light so
you've been paying him monthly it's
coming out of your payroll i mean it's
coming out of your chest i actually no
that's fine
yeah
did you did you have an agreement in
writing with him that you would pay him
out over a certain period of time
i actually had an agreement to pay him a
specific amount paid him that specific
amount
he said he would no longer represent me
after a certain amount of time because
of covid it extended extended extended
extended extended so because i find the
initial paperwork and everything covered
wise extended yes i owe him this amount
of money
okay so have you called him have you all
sat down and talked or does he think
usually you get a demand letter it's
because you're delinquent in payments
has he been trying to connect with you
and you're avoiding him why is he
sending you why did why did he this is
his his first option
i think it's twofold one because no
attorney's gonna take me on to represent
against another attorney
and two because he wants his money now
i think it's just you know i'm sure he's
been
you know shafted by others
i just don't have it he knows very well
i don't have it i've contacted him twice
in the course of six months and said
listen we have this agreement this is
what i had i told you you told me
i just i i'm stuck and i don't know how
to look at this
outside of my own head so i was just
hoping maybe i could get a fresh
perspective of do i rework this that
snowball and
sell my car because the car is the
biggest question mark in my mind well
how are you gonna get to and from work
get to the grocery store uh uber or lyft
i work from home okay um
does your car get you out of your debt
with this attorney
no it'll get me about
if he wants 16 grand and he can settle
on that and not cause me any more grief
i have one commission check coming in
it'll probably knock out half of it
hold on so let's let's back up for a
second
your assumption that attorneys don't
want to sue other attorneys is a hundred
percent false i know several attorneys
that love
taking on crooked attorneys
they hate that people are out there
poisoning the profession and they're
happy too
i'm not saying he's poisoning but i'm
just saying
honestly i i don't feel he did an
equitable job in what he did to me okay
all right so
being equal i do owe him i'm not trying
to say differently so let's take the
emotion out of this then you have a 16
000 debt that just got called
yeah right
are you able to go get a loan for this
money and pay him
no that's that's where i'm having the
difficulty i'm packed
like i said i took the original 401k
loan to give to him
so now we're talking you know i have no
other resources i am just i'm a single
mom
i work three jobs i don't have any more
resources and i totally don't have any
more time on friday so regina he's
trying to scare you let's let's forget
about let's let's let's forget about him
for a moment because he actually knows
you don't have it
so
if we could let's just can how how many
lines do we have in the debt snowball so
we got 16 000 to the lawyer what else do
you have in your snowball
8 000 for the car and a 1200 small just
a small loan that i took out to cover
expenses because i knew some other stuff
was coming
okay and then what's on the 401k i mean
i know that's coming out but i still
want to know what that loan amount is
it's currently at 5 000 just just at 5
000. right so we have 16 000 a lawyer 8
000 on the car 5 000 401 k loan 1200 and
another loan is that it
correct
okay
and um
you're telling me with your three jobs
you're absolutely maxed out you're
paying everything you can right now are
you putting money towards the 1200 on
the debt snowball you've been working
for five years that tells me you're not
making any progress
um well the problem is i have to hire an
attorney every two years my ex-husband
takes me back to court for more child
support
and this latest
2020 episode increased my child support
by 25 so i'm i'm literally reworking the
budgets and the baby steps all right so
single year all right so i'm trying to
help you practically very quickly here
so
the car is worth how much i know you owe
eight what's the car i can get eight for
it i do think i can get eight for it so
that would wipe it out totally so that's
a massive chunk right there
i mean here's what we teach
we teach working the debt snowball
you're in a situation where you've got a
lot of variables coming at you and i
think as far as this lawyer goes
i'm trying to channel dave right now and
i think you get tough with this guy and
go hey dude yeah so let me just be
honest with you you know i ain't got it
we can look at it you come after me all
you want you're not gonna get a dime
until i can get healthy and i can get
set and i'm gonna take care of this um i
can work a payment plan and give him a
little bit he can get a little bit of
something and you can put that in the
snowball um on based on a payment plan
but that's that's all he can get you
can't let his bullying and fear tactics
make you make another poor decision
that's right so i'm sending him a
certified letter that i'd make a copy of
and let him know here's you know that i
can't do this here's our original
agreement here's how it got just kicked
it got expanded through covet here's my
financial situation which you know by
the way i do not have 16 000 i've
already
loaned against my
uh 401k but
i will commit to paying you this much
over the next few months and we will go
from there
and
that's the best you can do if he wants
to sue you in court cool they're gonna
put a judgment against you and you're
gonna be in the same spot you're gonna
have a 16 000 debt except it'll be plus
court cost or whatever right and here's
the thing i'm going to hook you up with
a free session with a financial coach
one of our coaches okay so i want you to
hang on the line and someone's going to
walk through this specifically with you
but i want you to keep in mind what ken
just said
if you are out of options
i want you to rest in that
and i know that sounds bonkers
but there's nothing else
looking at these same numbers for three
nights in a row doesn't make new numbers
right it doesn't make a new there's not
a magic solution that you just it's not
a rubik's cube you just gotta turn it
the right way you gotta say you got a
bully coming after you for your money
and let's just be fair to him you owe
him this money
and now we got to figure out a plan to
get him paid back and so that means
you're gonna he won't talk to you on the
phone like a grown up send him a letter
and make sure that he uh signs for it
i'm gonna say this i think you need a
win regina i'd sell the car if you can
truly get around and do what you got to
do via uber i'd do it i'd sell the car
now we got a 1200 loan we can attack
that then we'll figure out the payment
plan to the lawyer get some victories
our coach will help you this is the
ramsay show